この七番目です この七番目
さ ヤッサ・ヴィタッカ・ヴィドゥッピタ
アッジャッタン・スィカッピタ・アセッサ
ソー・ビクク・ジャハーティ・オーレ・パーラン
ウラ・ゴ・ジンニャ・ニワ・タチャン・プラーナ
ヤッサ・ヴィタッカ・ヴィドゥッピタ
アッジャッタン・スィカッピタ・アセッサ
ソー・ビクク・ジャハーティ・オーレ・パーラン
ウラ・ゴ・ジンニャ・ニワ・タチャン・プラーナ
この日本語訳見ると 想念を焼き尽くして
余すことなく心の内がよく整えられた修行者は
この世とこの世の共に捨て去るという意味ですか
この偈の意味なんですけど
ヤッサ・ヴィタッカ・ヴィドゥッピタ
誰かのヴィタッカっていうのは
この頭の中で考えることなんですね
だから考えることをヴィドゥッピタっていうのは
まあ全部捨て去ってということで
まあ一応焼き尽くしということで
まあ全部焼き尽くしていると
だから考え方といったっていうのは
考えてない 考えられないっていうことではなくて
このヴィタッカだから
この概念のことなんですね
いろんな概念 想念 そういうのは一つもないということ
で 二行目は私のの意味で言えば
アッジャッタン・スィカッピタ・アセッサ
アッジャッタン 自分の心の中で
スィカッピタっていうのは
よーくよくもあの考えて考えて作った概念全てを
アセッサ 余すことなく
ヴィドゥッピタ 焼き尽くした
で この日本語訳では 内の中がよく整えられた修行者はと書いてますけど
そこはどこからそうなってるかちょっとわからないんですね
このテキストの中はありましたけどね
テキストはないね  ああだこうだと
個々別々の存在を思考することをすっかり振り切っていて
内なる精神において余すところなく完全に断ち切ってしまっているならば
って書いてある  あの これあの悟りの世界を説明するところで
人間の心の中でいろいろ概念がありまして
考え方があります で その考え方っていうのを
いわゆる概念っていうのは
すべて心の中から消えてしまうんですね
焼き尽くしてしまうんです
で その人は悟りという境地に達してるんだということで
だからこの心の内がよく整えられた修行者はっていうのは
まあそれは原文にはないんです
それは心の内がよく整えられたではなくて
心の内でよく作り出した想念をすべて焼き尽くした修行者はという意味なんです
そこを訳はまあこの中丸先生の訳だから
まあまあこれ絶対的なことだと信頼しているんだから
まあちょっとわからないということで
よし ヨーロッパの仏教学者やら哲学学者やら
そういう間では大変深く深く勉強されているところなんですけど
まあ 最近の哲学的な思考を作っている人々も
この そのいろんな概念についていろんなことを喋っていて
とにかくこの定義というやつは成り立たないと
その現代思想で言っているのは
ただノミネート ノミネールという言葉使ってますけどね
エッセンシャルとノミネールと二つに分けて考え方
何か内容あるようなものを取っていることはエッセンシャルで
そういうの何もないというふうに取るのはノミネールで
まあ哲学者は 現代哲学者はやっぱりこのエッセンシャルミーニングというものはないというふうに取っているんですね
ですから  お釈迦様は昔からやっぱりそれってノミネールとして取っているんですから
そこら辺は あんまり説明したくないんですね
いろいろ状況見ると するべきかないかとちょっと疑問なんですけど
まあわかる人はまあそれ誰か理解すればよろしいとは思いますけど
人間っていうのはやっぱり
概念でないと生活できないんですね
何か概念作る で 頭の中でいっぱい概念たくさんあるんですね
だから勉強してるっていうことは
いろんな概念たくさん作ることで
普通生活しているということは
もうたくさん概念が作っていると
だから好きか嫌いか いいか悪いかとかね
まあ木ですよと 木ではないんですよ
建物ですよということさえも全て概念なんですね
人間ですよというのも
動物ですよというのも概念であって
だから一切の言葉は概念なんですね
で 言葉だけではなくて
言葉でないものも概念としてはあるんですね
全て人間の感情やら経験っていうのはね
言葉で表すことができるわけじゃないし
でも目で見て 目で耳で見たり聞いたりして
ありったけの概念が頭の中では浮かぶ
現れていくんですね その頭の中で現れる概念には全部言葉があるんだと思ったら
それは大勘違いで 言葉あるのは一部だけなんですね
言葉がない概念もたくさん頭の中であるんですね
そこでそういう全て概念はもう悟りということでもなくなってしまうんですね
だからこれは木ですか
建物ですかっていう概念さえないんですね
だからそこはまあ悟ったところの境地
だから建物ですか？あるいは大きな木ですかと聞いたら
それは建物でしょう 木ではありませんというところで
そこで煩悩があるんですね
心の中で ですから この概念がない世界
仏教の世界なんですね
まあすべてわからないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりまあ引っかかってるっていうところは
人間の心はね 執着して捉われてるっていうことは
この概念があるんだからなんですね
ですから この目で何か見ると
何か概念作ってしまっちゃうんです
耳で何か聞くと そこで概念作る
で 言葉すべて概念 その概念っていうのはすべて嘘
簡単にそれだけです 頭の中で考えているものは一切全体ひとかけらもなく
すべてもう完璧な嘘なんです
何一つも実体あるわけじゃないんです
一言言葉でもう全部切り捨てれるだけで
それをもう折衝する必要はないんです
折衝してまた新しい限界になるだけで
人間の人間が頭の中で何を考えたっても
どのように考えたっても
言葉で考えていることであれば
自分の感覚で考えていることでであるならば嘘なんです
そんなことは そういうのはすべて焼き尽くしてるんです
そういう経験は悟りの境地なんです
だからしっかりしている心で
その人にはもう悟った人にとっては何をどんな概念持ってきたっても別に関係ないんですね
だから うん まあだから絶対的で安定している心だと言うんですね
だからまあ悟りはわからない
わからないと言ったっても
わからないのもわからない
わかりますけど で 概念がなくなったということは
まあこの前にあるのはまあサボテンですか？入れたらね
ないそうですよと言っちゃう
サボテンっていう概念なんですね
この何色で赤いんですよ
これ概念な嘘なんです
これは赤いサボテンだって見ている限りは
煩悩からは脱出することはできないんです
だから じゃあ心を整えていって
心を集中して じゃあ一体これは何ですかと
見たことがありますかと
見られたことはありますかと
経験したことはありますかと
経験したならば それは単なる概念だけ
概念のみということはわかるんですね
で 最近まで西洋哲学ではこのものをやっぱり実在論で
この前説明したこのエッセンシャルという
まあやっぱり科学の世界ではね
ものに定義するということがありまして
だから定義しちゃったら
まあそこはもう決まって止まってるような感じがすると
で そこは良くないんだと
定義はできませんと ものは説明できませんという哲学も出ていて
何一つ説明できませんだけど
これは何やってるんですかというぐらいは言えばいいんですかという
このファンクションだけ説明しましょうと
で それで あの まあ英語ではすごい面白い例えとかね
出して そこら辺は説明してますから
どうそう 現代西洋哲学のテキストいっぱいありますので
まあ読んでみて下さい
日本語訳あるかどうか分かりませんですけどね
かなり立派なことは書いてます
ただ 昔の哲学者よりはもうかなりいいことが書いてます
もうカントやらね そういう連中とは違って
いくらかはまともなことを考えてはいるんですけど
で 仏教でもやっぱりすべてのものはただ単に言葉だけですよと
で パンニャッティマートラボーハラマートという言葉を使って
まあもう別に何にも実体あるわけじゃなくて
まあただ単にまあ 本でしょうと言ったって
それただの言葉だけであるだけで
本があるわけじゃないってことで
だから頭きれいになるっていうことは
概念からきれいになるっていうことなんですね
概念がある限り頭はきれいにならないんですね
で 何か例えば聞いたら
我々は怒ったりする 例えば私はこの日本の仏教を批判したりすると
日本の仏教の方々はかなり腹が立ったり
機嫌が悪くなったりする
どちらにせよ だって二人ともそうやって言葉でからくりやってるんですね
人が何か喋ると なんで我々は怒ったりしますかというと
自分たちの頭の中で概念がいっぱい溜まっていて
その概念が実体であると正しいんだとと思ってるんですね
ですから そこでぶつかったりする
なんで人には何1つも
いくら言ったってさっぱりわからないんですかと
いくら何を説明してやっても
人っていうのは全く理解しないんでしょう
寝ているんだからずっと
あれも頭の中理解する余裕がないんですね
頭は概念というすごいクソでいっぱいぎゅうぎゅうと溜まってるんです
だから何一つもわからないんです
そこで説明すると 自分知ってる言葉
また あ なんとか先生がこうこう言った
そういうあれでしょうに
はい そうですと言ったらすごく落ち着いて
ああなるほどと 質問する時でもそうでしょう
で まあ自分が小さい時から浄土真宗で信仰してやってきて
まあこれこれぐらいお世話になっていて
まあこういうことで まあじゃあいかがでしょうかと質問するんですね
まあそれはそれで結構ですよという答えしかもう答えさえないんですね
だから質問してる人は自分の頭の中でこういう答えを出せというまでも言ってるんですね
だからその質問して困って困って
質問する人が困り果てて
困り果てているんだけど
自分の頭の中でまた答えも作ってるんですね
それで誰かに質問を出したら
その質問された側がこの本人の頭の中でできている答えをきちんと言ってあげれば
ものすごい万々歳で素晴らしい先生でしたと
よくわかって正解して答えていただけましたというか
かえって喜んでいくんですね
大体世の中でよくあるのはそういうことで
概念だけのことで それはまあ誰にでもできます
答えることは 人の機嫌を取って人を喜ばせてあげることは
バカであればあるほど簡単にできます
だからカウンセリング
相談 ディスカッションとかいうものだったら
カウンセラーになる 上手なカウンセラーっていうのはものすごくとてつもないアホなんですね
そうするととっても簡単にできるんです
カウンセリングを受ける側がいっぱい概念溜まって困って困って
それには解釈まで持ってるんだから
だからカウンセラーの人にとっては
他の違う概念なんかは丸っきり浮かばないんですね
ああ そうですね その通りですよって言っちゃえば
それだけで終わっちゃうんです
だからそこら辺は本当はもう喋れないんですよ
難しすぎて 嘘を言ってはいけないと言ったら腹が立って喧嘩している社会では
そんなことを喋れないと思っちゃいますけどね
この芸はすべって飛ばして他のところに行きたいところなんですけど
でもそこら辺 悟りということを経験しないで
一応私は仏教を知っているんだという
自慢したければ やっぱり勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
まあ とにかく頭の中で
頭っていうのは概念でしか動かない
ご飯食べるかパン食べるかと考えたら
自分が一つ選べなくちゃいけないんですね
選べないで両方食べる人もいるんだけど
それも一つの考え方で一つ選ぶということをする場合もありますね
だからいっぱい概念がないと
どうやって一つ選ぶんですかね
ご飯にするかパンにするかという
いっぱい頭の中で概念がないと一つ選ぶことはできないんですね
で 勉強すると思ってね
勉強すると思ってやることもいっぱい概念
頭の中でたくさんたくさん作ることなんですね
概念の一部には言葉があります
一部には また 言葉がない概念というのはすごいたくさんあります
概念という意味は私はわかりません
私は英語でこのconceptという言葉言ってるんだからね
だから概念についてもすごい概念を持ってるでしょ
だからどうしようもないんです
説明もできないんですね
理解するということは
もう概念で理解する 頭の中で自分知ってる何かの概念に比べて
新しい概念を作ると それで自分知ってることはについてすっごい執着持ってるんですね
自分が何か食べたところで
それはものすごくあまりにも苦くて
もう気持ち悪かったとすると
それは絶対的だとそこでもう決めつけてるんです
で ああいう食べたものは気持ち悪くてまずいものではなく
最高なものですよと もう一つの人が
もう一人の人は概念を持ってるかもしれません
そこでその人々は自分たちの概念にものすごくしがみすぎてるんですね
しがみすぎてるんだから
それからいろんな苦しみ
悩みが生まれてくるんですね
だから 二つの概念 違う概念を持ってる二人がお互いにぶつかり合わなくちゃいけないんですね
ぶつかり合ったりして
それから相手の概念を抑えて壊したりしなくちゃいけないんだよ
自分の概念を正当化するために
自分の概念を生かすために
そうやって頭の中に自分が作っている概念は
一つ全て何とかしてもう生かしてやれよということで
もう大変残酷なことを世の中でしているんでしょうに
[犬の鳴き声]だから恐ろしく
そうやって概念にしがみついて
概念を守っていこうという恐ろしいことを世の中で起きてるんですね
昔からずっと 概念でなければご飯食べることもできませんしね
で 自分持っている概念は正しいと守っていようともするし
そうすると違う概念を持ってる人々との喧嘩したりもするし
そこで仏教の世界 仏教わかろうと思って仏教を勉強してやったらわかるわけじゃないし
とんでもないことで ただ新しい概念作るだけ
それで面白いことは 新しい概念作る人にとっては頭が増えますけど
ほとんど新しい概念作れません
だから何年仏教勉強したでもどうしてもどうったことないっていうことはありますし
それはもう自分の頭の中でずっと持っている概念をあっちこっちあっちこっち
あの こちらに前にあるものは後ろに置いたり
後ろにあるものを左に置いたりする
ちょっとした整理してるだけ
だからこの若い人々はね
勉強しちゃうと いろんなことを理解してしまっちゃってびっくりするでしょう
だからそういう概念ないんだよね
概念ないんだから 頭の中で新しい概念作らなくちゃいけない
初めて勉強する仏教のすぎて
そうするといくらか頭の概念増やしちゃって
いくらか勉強したことになりますけど
まあ経験豊富で学問ものすごい深い学問をしている人々だったら
もう勉強する理解する量っていうのは 0 なんですね
勉強できない 何言っても自分が過去から持っている概念は整理して置いておくだけ
だから随分理解早く見えるんです
すごいいっぺんに理解しましたと
そこでもうその方々に経験豊富だ豊富で
勉強深い方々に何か言って
またそれは何でしょうかと
サマリーで なんて言いますか
まとめて言ってくれと
丁寧にまとめてみせるんですね
瞬時に そうすると一般人はすごくびっくりするんですね
もうやっぱり私はさっぱりわからなかったんだけど
あの先生一回聞いただけできれいに整理して説明までしてるんだと
あれは勉強してないんだからなんです
そもそも自分の頭の中で持っていた概念だからね
それの位置変えただけ
なかなか新しい概念心に入るっていうこともまた難しいし
概念で詰まって溜まってるし
だから概念って何だろうかということで考えなくてはならないし
まあ一応瞑想指導する人々には
まあその世界はわかりやすく一応説明してやりますからね
まあわかってるだろうと思いますけど
瞑想の方式を欲しがる人にとっては
で これは座布団ですよということも概念
概念であって事実ではありません
だから でも科学的な世界で説明しなくちゃいけないんだから
そこで哲学者言うのは
まあ機能ぐらいは説明しておきましょうと
座布団があるわけじゃなくて
まあ機能ぐらいは説明しておきましょうということで
これ何のためやと聞いたら
まあ座るためぐらいで
で まあ説明しておけばいいんじゃないかと
だから座布団という概念あるんだからこそ
もう形決まってあって
厚さが決まってあってとかね
もし誰かが三角のもの作っちゃったら
なんだこれと それ変ですよと
日本ではそういう習慣ないんですよと
すっごくもう胸を張って喧嘩に来るんですね
何か言ったら 何か違うこと言ったら
ああ 日本ではそんな習慣ありませんと
だから言ってることをまるっきりもう屁理屈と言っても
もう屁理屈で嫌なほど屁理屈ですけど
もう何か言って まあ固定概念を守ろうとしている
だからそこは煩悩であって
それでまあ一生懸命いくら頑張ってもまあ意味がなくて
煩悩はそのままで ただ単に瞑想してすっごい高慢と強力な欲と煩悩を作っただけで終わるんですね
だからそれも恐ろしくて
まあこれで勝手に自由にいろんな方法で瞑想して
もうできたぞと思う人だったら
もう私たちには全くもう手に負えない
もうあまりにもきついんですね
その煩悩のきつさっていうのは
どうしようもないんです
そういう人々は 一応瞑想指導する場合は全く失格というふうにまあ捨てちゃうんです
概念にとらわれるということも大変なことなんですね
そこでどこかのこういう道場でこういうふうに瞑想をやってるんだ
こういうところでこういうふうに瞑想をやってるんだ
ああいうところでこういうふうにやってるんだとかね
情報まで持ってきて そこで比較もして比べてみて
じゃどうだ？言うと 永遠の失格だと
もう何もやらないと だからまあもっともっと研究してくださいよ
道場をとことんとことん巡って巡ってみてくださいと
追い出すと言って責任を負う
もうすごい恐ろしいことなんですね
だからこの瞑想の世界でも
それは大変な恐ろしいことで
とにかくもう自分で概念作って
たとえ時々はカトリックの人々は仏教の瞑想でもやってみようではないかと
来てやって では悟りますか？と
悟らないことはもう確固たる事実なんです
なぜかというと 自分では概念を持ってるんだから
だからいくらやったって概念は壊れていくことはないんです
そこでちょっと心柔らかい人が来て
私と喋ったところで 私はまあ大体二十分以内で
今までのもう六十歳であろうが七十歳であろうが
今まで作り建ててきた一切の概念を壊してみせるんだけど
それにまた文句を言うんですね
なんて坊主ですかと という新しい概念を作る
意地悪しているんだと
人を馬鹿にするんだと
言って とにかく心は自由にさせませんと
安らぎは絶対どうやったっても
それだけはもう消しますよということで頑張っているんです
安らぎ 心の安らぎというもの
平安というものは それはいくなる理由があっても拒否しますと
どう納得 説得させたっても
他のは認めますけど それだけは嫌と
というものすごい心の働きがあり
それも概念なんです だからこの悟りということは
初期仏教の世界ではね
最も簡単な もう淡々と誰々誰でもさささっと渡してしまったし
でももうどんどんどんどんこれも絶対無理なものになってしまったんですね
それはこの概念にとらわれているということ
そこでこの そこをわかってないんですね
まあ申し訳ないんだけどね
中村先生 で なんでそういう訳してないかというと
この注釈書を見ると 注釈書でもそこを注視でないんですね
注意していないんだから
自分でもまあ とこまねるところがなくて
注意するところじゃなくて
当たり前のことだからね
普通のパーリだから注意を入れてないんで
専門用語以外に注意入れませんだから
あるいは英訳で間違ってるかもしれません
だからこちらで言ってるのは
人々というのは頭の中でよくよく考えて
よく情報をいろんなことを比較して比較して
比べて比べて 研究して
研究して 自分でいろんなものを理解していくでしょうに
ただ空見ていたんだからといって頭が良くなるわけないでしょうに
世の中の知識人っていうのは
もうものすごい苦労して
いろんな学問という修行して
実験して 研究して上で来ている知識なんです
で 今ものすごい計算速い
恐ろしいほどの計算 速いのいろんな電気機械を使って
そこでもう人間にはもう一億年
二億年でもかかるぐらいの計算をもう二
三秒でやってもらって
それからまた考えて考えて
やっと作っている概念なんですね
だから心の中でよく整理して整えていると概念なんです
アッジャッタン・スウィカッピタ
自分の心の中でものすごく考えて出来上がっているものなんですね
まあわかりやすい例なんですよ
例えばこの神様を信仰している人々
阿弥陀さんを信仰している人々が
もうかなり苦労して かなりテキストを読んで
かなり勉強して そういう考え方に至っているんです
だから我々には この限りない苦しみを作ってくる概念は
ついていてもものだというよりも
こちらで苦労して苦労して獲得しているものなんです
だからバカはそんなに苦しまないでしょ
人生については あのもう別にあまり物事を考えない人はそれなりに軽々く生活しているし
人間の世界を見たっても時々知識的なそれほど知識成長しない人々いるでしょ
いつでもニコニコと笑っているんですね
だから誰とも喋るそういう人々は相手が誰かとあまりわからないんです
お母さんがちゃんと愛しなさいと教えてあげたら
もう誰にでも挨拶して歩くんですね
それ以上考えません で
概念持ってる人々から見れば変な人やと
やっぱり病気だと頭が悪いと思うかもしれませんだけど
でも逆らえないんです
そういう人には 全く知らない人なんですけど
いきなり挨拶しちゃうと
こちらもなんとなく挨拶しなきゃいけないんです
まあとにかく軽々く生活しますね
まあ人間というのはものすごい苦労して
勉強して 頑張って頑張って概念を作ってるんですね
ですから概念 のは捨てにくいんです
概念って だから私は現象という言葉をいつでも使っているし
で 幻覚とかね 妄想とか
そういう言葉も使っているし
だからわかりやすく言えば
目を開けたら頭に映るのは幻覚なんですね
そこは修行でもって体験していかないと
で 我々には目を開けた途端
赤い作務衣が目に映っちゃうんですね
それは概念です 赤い作務衣だと思った瞬間で煩悩が生まれているんです
なぜなら何が煩悩かというと
私とこの赤い作務衣の関わり
リレーションシップ 関係というものが生まれるんですね
必ずしもそこで関係っていうものが生まれるんですね
どうやってそこから離れるんですかね
見ただけでもう煩悩が束縛生まれているんです
リレーションシップが
関係がもう成り立っているんです
ということで 見ることで
聞くことで 味わうことで
煩悩は生まれて生まれて生まれて
もうキリがなく もうリレーションシップというものはもう成り立っていっちゃうんです
だからどう見るべきかということなんですね
だからそこを切った人が悟ったんだとよくわかるんです
誰かに免許欲しいとかね
私は悟ったと何とか先生言いましたとと言ったりもします
私は何とか道場に行って年いて
そうやって肩書見せたりするとかね
もうそれとはもう違う
何の疑いもない関係切っちゃったんだからね
大変ですけどね すごいわかりやすいこの世界を体験するの
だから瞑想したっても
もうなんだか古臭い このクソのような概念持ってくる
ヨガのことを持ってくるわ
もう中国のなんかくだらん腹が立ちますけど
何か持ってくるわ ヨーロッパではこのようにやっているんだからと言ってくる
それでまた仰せじゃ やっぱりその通りやらなくちゃと
このボスはもう言うこと聞かない頑固で
もうあまりにも古臭くてとかね
ある日すごく馬鹿にされたことあります
私も全く現代的なことを知らないんだと言う人に
私は言い返しはしなかったんだけど
言いたかったのはね あなたは自分の周りのことも知らないんだと
もうただの生きてる化石やとと言いたかったんだけど
私は随分半分も以上年下ですけどね
まあちょっと英語ほんのちょっと喋られるぐらい
それぐらいのことで なぜ馬鹿にされたかというと
その人に言ってることはなんとなく分かりました
私が言っていることはなぜ分かりましたかというと
こちらで必死で苦労してね
その本人が分かっている範囲で説明しちゃったんです
それでも西洋のなんとかさん
なんとかさん なんとかさんに言い逃れしなかったんだからね
自分持ってるすごい固定概念で
この南アジアの人間っていうのは頭が悪くて原始的で
もう馬鹿者もだめと その中でスッキさんはもっと酷いんだと
何も知らんんだよと という固定概念があるんだから
まあよくよく言うんですね
だから喧嘩しては意味がないしね
冷静に説得してあげようとか
それまた概念の喧嘩になりますからね
で とにかくそれなんか持ってきて
現代でアメリカでやってる方法でヴィパッサナーやりましょうとかね
あるいは中国のもう年じゃなくて
1億年古いと言ってもいいんだけど
1億年ぐらい古い伝統の瞑想のやり方でやりましょうとかね
で まあとにかくその方にこういう風にやらなくちゃ意味がないんだと
我々現代人には気に入らないんだと
だから現代人に気に入られる方法を教えるということは
結局現代人が持っている概念をもうほんのちょっと位置変えてるだけでしょうに
何も新しい知恵が生まれたことじゃないんで
だから仏陀の世界はもうそんなもう教団の世界じゃないんです
全てのものはもうやっぱり概念で幻覚であるというふうなことで
捨ててるんですね えーあの
今日はこの儀は当たると思わなかったんです
思ったら僕これ飛び出しますけどね
私が自分個人としては一番明確に理解しているところ
故に誰にも説明してあげたくない
で あの まあ一応単純にこれだけ覚えてる
これは赤い作務衣ですよと思った途端
目を開けて見た途端 これと私という概念が関係が生まれてくる
それはもう世俗的な世界で
悟りの世界ではありません
だから私という概念がなくて
概念は生まれません これは赤いですよというために
あるいはこれは黒いですよというために
これは絵ですよというために
こちら私がいるんですよということがないと
成り立たないんですね
ここで私がいる あ Aですと言うんです
あ これはAですよと 全然気が付かないでしょうに
その時は これはAです
え？というAですではいりません A
その一言葉の概念を作るためには
私というものを存在しないと成り立たないんですね
そうすると そちらで関係表れてしまうんですね
それが煩悩なんです 私という概念も証明出してない妄想概念であって
成り立たないんですね
ヨーロッパでこのもう少々前のですけど
ブーバーとかなんとかとかね
徹底的に証明しようと思ったのは関係なんですね
素晴らしいんだと だから彼が言ってることで
僕今日似てるんじゃなくて
まるっきり正反対なんです
彼がありがたく言ったのは
この関係なんですね 私と他の関係
それで私と神との関係と
私とあなたといったら
私とあなたの間で関係が生まれるでしょうと
故に神がいるんだと 言葉があるんだから
神という それですごい有名な世界的に認められる哲学者で
だからもうどうすればいいかわからないんだけど
まあ言語学を教えるってことはね
もう僕らにはもうどのほどの言語学で言ってることはあまりにも言語はね
でも内容はもうあまりにも単純で
もう無意味なんですね
だからそこでAですと言った途端 A
という一言葉作った途端
花という一言葉作った途端
そこに私がいるんだということを成り立ってしまって
そこで私と花との関係が成り立ってしまって
その関係は煩悩であって
花から離れられなくなるんですよ
そこで じゃあ外に花があるんだというと思うことは概念で
問題はそこにあったんだから
でも関係は心の中だけで生まれるんですからね
だから自分だけの世界でずっと苦しんでるんですね
まあ成り立たないということは
この前も説明しましたから
一応悟った人によってははっきりと概念がない
全部もう焼き尽くしてます
だから誰とも喧嘩しない
誰でもいい悪いとも思わない
思えないんだから いいかと悪いかと
自分という実感もない
まあ見えたり聞いたりするんだけど
それで世俗的に一時的に言葉使ったり
論理的にしたりする だからただそういうすべてはただ単に言葉だけですよと
まあ世俗的にほんのちょっと
ただちょっとした概念だけですよと
ということではっきり注意して喋ったりする
だからパンニャッティマッタン
ゴーハーラマッタンというもう大変な素晴らしい言葉で
まあ残念ながら日本語には訳できませんですけどね
まあ普通我々ね 人を傷つけたら
まあ彼がただ遊んでるだけでしょうと
あんたちょっとからかってるだけでしょうと
そんな気にするなという時あるでしょうね
あの人こういうふうなことを言うんだと
私に対して と言って自分がすごい神経質になっちゃって
それで第三者が まあまあ気にしなくてもいいんだよ
あれ彼はあれ ただからかってるだけですよと
そんな気にする必要ないんだよと言ったら
ああからかってるだけですか
ということは この人言ってる言葉には意味がないってことでしょうね
あ だったら別にどうったことはないんだと
言葉に意味があると思ったら
そんなうまくはいかないんですね
大変苦しみが生まれてくる
ですから まあそういうふうなちゃんと小さな例を見ても
概念に囚われることはいかに苦しみが生まれてくるかという
本当はみんなただからかってるだけなんですね
この科学とかね 歴史とかね
数学とかね 医学とかね
別に大したことみんなからかってるだけ
ただ言葉だけなんで そんな気にする必要ないんです
どんなものにせよだと
まあそう分かればもう悟りの境地なんです
で まあ一応次に行きます
あまり行き過ぎだったらよくないし
申し訳ないんですけど
今日は難しい部分だったかもしれない Yo
na accasari na paccasari sabbam accagamā imaṃ papañcaṃ
so bhikkhu jāti ūu oorapāraṃ
purago jinna miva taccaṃ purāṇaṃ.これは八番目で
走っても早すぎることなく
また遅れることもなく
すべてこの妄想を乗り越えた修行者は
この世とかの世とをともに捨て去る
パーリ語の言葉見て覚えたってもいいし
もう大変な素晴らしい専門的な言葉だから Yo
na accasariというのは
この反対形の言葉が入ってますから accasari
それはもっと簡単なパーリ語ならaticariってなっちゃうんですね aticari
の前にnaというものが入って
これちょっと合体になっちゃって
合体させてna accasariという言葉に書き換かっちゃうんですね
それにはそれなりの法則がありますからね
それは文法を勉強するとき
パーリ語を勉強するとき勉強するんだからね
で aticariっていうのは行き過ぎ
[音楽]こちら皆様がこれ読むのはナアッチサリという言葉なんですけど
でもその中でアティサリという言葉作らなくちゃないと
あるいはアッチサリでもいいんです
あのえありますね えだけ取ってアッチサリ
そうするとちょっとわかりにくいんですけどね
まあアティサリアッチサリというのはやりすぎ
行きすぎ ナアッチサリっていうのは行きすぎでもない
そこで次の言葉ナッパッチサリ
パッチャっていうのは逆なんですね
だから前に行き過ぎでもなくて
逆だったら何と言いますか
後退することなんですね
反対側に行くことでもないんだと
前に行く行き過ぎでもない
反対側に行くことでもないと
サッバンアッチャガマイマンパパンチャン
この現象の世界すべて乗り越えていると
どういう意味でしょうかね
パパンチャンチャンというのは
この伝統的な仏教ではケロンとか訳するんですね
そうするとすごくわかりやすいでしょ
あれは間違い ケロンじゃないんです
でもいくら間違っていたとしても
すぐそれで理解するんだから
まあ私には別に関係ないんだけど
で パパンチャっていうのは英語で言えばフェノーメナというフェノメノンということで
普通日本語で言っているこの現象というものなんですね
現象っていうのは 目に光が入ったら頭の中で作る映像なんです
耳に音を触れたら頭の中で作る聴覚
それは現象なんですね
で 耳に音が触れる それぐらいはなんとなく推測できます
でも電車の音だと 故にあれは電車ですよということは
頭の中で作らなくちゃいけないんです
目にはバラの花どーんと来て
バラの花の映像が入ってきて焼き付いたということは絶対ありえないんです
目にはずーっと光が流れてぶつかって反射していく
光が流れてぶつかって反射して
すごい速さで光の速度っていうのは相当早いでしょうに
だからずーっと光が入って反射して帰って入って反射して返して帰っていく
バラの花なんか映るわけじゃないんです
そこでその過程が何かを目に光が映す映りっぱなしだったら
頭の中で何か イメージを作るんです
それは現象と言うんです
それはパパンチャと言うんです
だからその そのその人の頭の中で
それぞれ自分自分なりの映像
映像を作るんです 聴覚を作るんです
他の味覚も味覚も もう体の感覚もそれぞれ自分なりに何か作る
それはパパンチャと言うんです
だからこのあまりにも早すぎて
なかなか抜けられないかもしれませんですけど
まあそれは置いといて
だからいいということは言うんじゃなくてね
まあ音は音であって で
私たちの耳には音が触れたその瞬時にもう判断して現象を作って
それまたじーっと握ってもう終わってるんです
自分作った概念 うん まあ大体経験あるでしょうと思いますけど
忙しいんだったらそういう経験することはできませんだけど
あの まあ普通一人でいると
なんか鳥の声だというもの
一応音が耳に触れる 触れた瞬間で
まあ鳥の声だと なんて美しいかという気持ちになる
散歩をすると花が咲いた
なんて美しいだとと思ってしまう
それはもうみんな自慢するんですね
瞬間にそう思ってしまったんだと自慢しているんだけど
あれかなり時間経ってるんです
かなり時間経ってからそう思うんです
で 人間にとっては瞬間かもしれませんだけど
それで音が耳に触れたと
まあ感じて なんて美しい音かというふうに感じてしまったとします
その感じたものはパパンチャであって
ケロンであって現象なんです
それでそれについてものすごい執着が起きてるんですね
私のもの なんて美しいですかっていうこと自体も執着であって
なんて気持ち悪いんですかということも執着で煩悩であります
そこは捨てないと悟りっていうことは成り立たないんで
この体の中で起きるこの現象の流れ
現象が来ては消える 来ては消えると
幻覚なんですけど この幻覚が起こすこの過程を破らなくてはならないんですね
それに新しい幻覚を作って
私にいろいろ褒めてくれ
褒めてくれと言ったってもね
まあ正直な人には褒められませんだけどね
まああの とにかくこの現象っていうものは心の中でずっと生まれるんですね
現象っていうのは目から生まれる
耳から生まれる で 音を聞いて
我々はいろんなことを考えて考えるでしょ
目で何か見たら それについていろんなことを考える
勝手に作るということはよく分かりますよ
なぜならば 私が作ってる世界と他の人が作っている世界はなぜ違いますかと
同じ世界にいるならば
同じ音を聞くならば どれだったらみんな同じでしょう
そうじゃなくて それぞれ人間
人間みんな違うでしょうに
その違うということは
みんなどんな幻覚を作っているかということなんですね
だから答えは何ですかね
その そんなに幻覚に囚われるべきですかと
我々は人間のこの差にすごい囚われてるでしょうに
これは私の世界だと 私が考え出した世界だと
私は何年間も頭の中で蓄積して
もう修行して積み重ねてきた世界だと
それは幻覚だと言ってるんです
あなたの内なる世界も
こちらの内なる世界も
全部幻覚で 幻覚によってみんなバラバラで別々になっているという新しい幻覚が生まれているんですね
それも幻覚ですけど だから音が耳に触れるのは
俺は別にどうってことなく
それしょうがないんですよ
物質の流れだから でも頭の中でそれ聴覚っていうのは幻覚なんですね
聴覚に付いて生まれてくる概念というのはパパンチャがそこはそんなに大事じゃないんだと
でもそれ大事だと思っちゃうんですね
だから二人が同じ音を聞いてるんだったら
同じ幻覚を作るはずですけど
同じ幻覚作りませんだから
それはいい加減 だから世界ではとても意味があると思っているものは
仏教では全く意味がないんだと理解した方が分かりやすいんです
音が耳に触れてるんだという言葉は
みんなつまらないと言うんですね
それが意味があるんです
音が耳に触れる 触れる
それはみんなに同じなんです
ヘッドフォンステレオを例えば個ぐらい持ってきて
同じ拡声機というかアンプリファイアでつなげてあげれば
みんな同じ音を聞いてるでしょうに
同じエネルギー そこは事実
それは大事なんです 耳に触れるのは同じ音ということが
そこでその人の人はインタビューしてみたところで
どんな感じ どんな感じ
どんな感じかと むちゃくちゃバラバラでしょうに
ヘッドフォン 10個で 10人が同じ音を聴いたっても
10人が作った主観が違うんだから
あれは意味がないんだと我々は言ってるんです
あなたの頭で出来上がった妄想はあまり意味がないんだと
でも 実際に科学的に耳に触れた音を無視して
頭の中で生まれた幻覚を大事にする
だから世の中には問題があると
これナーチャサーリーパッチャサーリーの意味が言い忘れたんだけど
もうやりすぎも良くないということで
だから まあ妄想にしても同じことでね
例えば何か音を聞いたりする
で 幻覚は起こす その幻覚から次の幻覚
次の概念 次の概念 次の概念
次の概念と切りがなくても概念流しちゃったらどうなるんですかね
ものすごい意味のないところになってしまっちゃうんですね
だから 例えば普通では考えすぎ考えすぎの人よりも何でも考えられるでしょうに
それも意味がない パッチサーリーといえば
このもうもう反対に 逆に行くということでね
で そこら辺も意味を言うと
少々またあの難しいところにぶつかるので
はぁ これ何か参照と書いてますけど
そこら辺探してみましょう
この数字 あの 一応簡単に説明します
あまり深く また二度とそういう芸には当たらないだろうとは思いますからね
あの ちょっと説明したい気持ちもありますけど
電気がないって心配して
うーん 物事 やり過ぎも良くないし
何もやらないということも良くないし
ですから この認識の過程においても同じことで
あの まあ認識のことを言ったんだ
例えば認識を追って追って行ってはいけないんですね
聞いたんだ じゃあ何ですか？それから何で？それから何ですか？それで何でそれは何ですかと
そうやっていくのはやり過ぎ
そこで ああ すべて現象か
じゃからだから聞かんようにするんだと
という否定して止まることは
もう止まることなんです
まあどうせ頭の中の概念というのは幻覚だから
意味がないんだから じゃあよかったと
何もやらないと 楽だとすぐ決めつけることまたもうとんでもない考え方です
結局自分をごまかしてるだけなんです
それはどっちでも良くないんだと
やっぱりその働きをちゃんと観察しなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことなんですけど
まあそれ全部 まあとにかく現象を乗り越えて
まあ皆様が知っている言葉で言えば
やり過ぎもなく止まることもないという言葉は大変大事なポイントで
仏教の修行方法なんですね
中道でやりなさいと やり過ぎといっても
あまり何か固定概念で決めてやり過ぎだから
そうすると全然意味がないんですね
やらんということは もう単なる止まっている怠けてることだから
ですから この中道的なこの修行方法を言ってるんですね
そこをずっと次から次の部分で
いつでもそれ使ってるんです
なんでもやり過ぎも良くないし
そこそこでも良くない
そこそこやるんだと そこそこヴィパッサナーやってるだけったって
別に何にも得られないんですね
じゃあやるんだと思ってやって全然何も得られませんしね
だからいつでも気をつけて
丁寧にちゃんとやり続けなくちゃいけない
これこのすごい微妙な中道のことを言ってるし
他の例で言えば あの 例えば色々ご飯食べちゃったらね
カロリーばっかり入っちゃって体が太りますよと
ああそう じゃあやめますと
それで絶食すると やり過ぎでしょうに
絶食したら じゃあ食べると
それでお腹に入る 入れるならば何でももう食べて食べてしまうと
これまたやり過ぎでしょうね
それ食べることにしたら分かりやすいでしょうね
あ もったいない じゃあ食べると
じゃあみんなもうみんなせっかく集めたんだから
じゃあ食べようと そうやってもう食べる
食べる 食べる それはもう食べ過ぎ
それでほんのもうコーラ1本でもどうですかと
やっぱりカロリー入っちゃったら太りますから
嫌ですよと じゃあお茶に茶菓子カロリー入りますから
太りますから 嫌ですよと
今日はご飯 ご飯を食べませんって
だったら死んじゃいますでしょうに
そうやってこれやり過ぎなんですね
どちらにしたっても それだったら自分の健康を守れるわけじゃないんで
だから人の道っていうのは
やり過ぎも良くないし
止まることも良くないんですね
いつでも気をつけてある中道を守らなくちゃいけない
その中道というのは やっぱりいつでもいい結果が出られる方法なんですね
だから 修行においても同じこと
ヴィパッサナー瞑想にしたっても同じことで
耳に音が触れたら妄想が生まれるんだと言ってね
耳を耳にまた穴開けて聞こえないようにするのは意味がないんですね
だからと言って妄想の病気が治ったわけでもないし
でまあ妄想だから とにかく聞いてやるぞと言って
じっとじっとずっとずっと聞いて
いっぱい妄想で作るする
起こるようにするのは意味がないんですね
だから修行においては中道のことを言ってるんです
うん とにかく瞑想して
すべてのものは現象だと思って
現象のレベルを乗り越える
現象のレベルを乗り越えたことは悟りという
これで 10番目になってくると
9番目は「サッバン ビタタン イダンティ ニャットワ ロク」で
やり過ぎでもなく 止まることでもなく
修行する人はすべてアンリアルだと
実体がないんだと 私というものにも実体がない
外の世界には実体がないんだと
全く実体がないということに気がつくんですね
これは 8番 9番目 一切のものは虚妄であると知って
本当は実体はないんだということはわかるんですね
だから こういうのは哲学的な虚妄ではありません
それだったら 大乗仏教の虚妄の世界や空の世界っていうのは
散々喋ってるんだから
あれはただの概念であって
悟りの世界ではないので
頭で何でも考えられるんだから
でも外に世界があるんですよ
仏教においては空ではなくて
で あるんだけど これはもう固定してあるんじゃなくて
恐ろしい勢いで変化している過程だけだと
映画と同じなんですね
映画はあると言っちゃえばあるんだけど
やっぱりプロジェクターという機械からずっと光が流れているんです
ただそれだけなんですね
だからアンリアルだと虚妄だと言うんであって
それ発見するんですね
こんな素晴らしい映画って何でしょうかと
スクリーンに映っているあまりにも美しい風景を見て
ああ すごい美しい そこをちょっと調べたところで
あら 光ではないかと あの光はこの機械が作っているのではないかと
ということは 映画はないというふうに理解しちゃうんですね
それはそういう理解であって
この そう理解した人は悟ってしまっちゃう
解脱してしまっちゃう
その人はまあ虚妄だと分かったら欲が消えてしまう
それで全ては虚妄だと分かったら
また老婆っていうのは老婆とラーガ
ラーガはちょっと強力な渇愛ですね
老婆は欲が消えてしまう
そこで全ては虚妄でアンリアルで実体がないんだと分かったら怒りが消えてしまう
全てが実体がないアンリアルだと思ったら
無知が消えてしまう  13番目までほとんど同じ偈は繰り返していくんですね
同じことで特に難しい意味がないです
ポイントはナンチャサリプッタパッキャサーリなんですけどね
14番目を見てみましょうか
ヤッサアヌセヤーナサンティケーチムーラアプサラサモハタセ
ヤッサアヌセヤー アヌセヤーっていうのは心の中に何か残っちゃうんですね
ある 何か溜まっちゃう
溜まったんだからまた後で出ちゃうんですね
そういう機能 我々みんな持ってるんですね
何か聞いちゃったら なんかちょっとしたことを残っちゃうんですね
例えば時々誰かのことを
誰か言ったこと 誰かやったことを見たら
もうなんか自分がちょっとちょっと怒ったり
気に入らなかったりする
あとで頭でそれぐらいのことで気にせんでもいいんじゃないかと自分には言ってますけど
あの人はわざとやったんではないし
もうまあついそんなことをただ言ったんだから
それぐらい気にしなくたっていいんではないかと
自分にはずっと言い聞かせてはいるんだけど
やっぱり何か残っているんですね
そういうことはよく心にあります
こんなちょっとのことなんですけど
自分でも頭では知ってるんです
別にそんなわざわざともよく考えてやったことでもなくて
まあもう気にしなくたっていいんだけど
でも気になってしまっちゃう
そう そういう働きは このアヌセヤーという心の中に何か残ってしまう働きがあるんですね
電車に座ったとか 隣になんか人がちょっともう失礼に座ってるんだとする
自分はちょっと邪魔だとする
だから居眠りして 自分の体に自動でこうやってもう倒れたとするでしょうに
その時はもうまず迷惑だと思っちゃう
またかえって頭の中で迷惑だ
嫌な人だとかね そんなことを思わなくたっても
どうせ誰でも居眠りしちゃうしね
しょうがないんじゃないかと
これはもういたってもそれ失礼し
まあ気にしなくたっていいんじゃないか
自分には言ってるんですよ
みんな まあそれぐらい人がね
眠くなってこうなってきたっていても
まあそう言ってはいるんだけど
やっぱり心の中で何か残っちゃうんですね
その働き 日常生活の中で我々にはずっとあるんですよ
だから毎日聞いたり 味わったり
考えたりするんだけど
やっぱりいつでも何か何か何か何か何か何か心の中で残って残って残って残って残っていっちゃうんです
これ 残るものは後から出るんでしょうに
後からかなりもう凶暴になって出たりする
そういうことで もう煩悩から解放できないんですね
だからヤッサアヌセヤーナサンティケーチ
もし誰かの心の中であの働きはないんだであるならば
何も見ても聞いても 心の中にちょっと入って残ることはないと
それ悟りの境地なんですね
どういうことでしょうかね
だから普通我々言うて気になって気になってましょうがないんだと
それはもう心に結構残ってるということなんですね
時々気になってしょうがないと言ったくはないんです
まあ別にそんなこと気にしなくても意味がないんだとかね
自分に言い聞かせてるんです
誰がそんなことを気にするんですかと
偉そうに言うんだけど
やっぱりちょっと残っているんですね
それはいつでもそうであるんです
そういう働きを覚えておいて
誰の心もあります それで
お釈迦様の修行法によってその機能がなくなっちゃう
残らないんですね 聞いたら聞いただけで終わっちゃう
で 人が何かすごい失礼なことを言ったりする
聞いただけで終わっちゃうんですね
残らない 残っちゃったら
あれ なんであなたそんなこと言いますか？とかね
その場で立ち上がる場合もあるし
後でどんどん溜まったところで自分が精神的に落ち込んですごい苦労する場合もあるし
だから悟りの世界では流れているんだと
こちらで音が流れていて
こちらの耳が流れていくんだからね
それで誰の実体がないんだから
残れるはずがないんですね
耳も川のように流れているし
音も川のように流れているし
他の部品も全部流れているんだ
そこに人がいるわけじゃないし
こちらに私がいるわけでもないんだから
残るという機能さえも全くないんですね
そういうことは悟りであって
それから なぜ残るかというムーラアクサラサモンハターセ
ムーラ ムーラっていうのは根元ですね
アクサラっていうのは不戦
サモンハタ 不戦の根というものは根っこ
根っこを 根っこをサモンハタ
全部取り捨てているんですね
十五見ましょうか ヤッサダラタジャーネサンティケーチオーランアーガマナヤパッチャヤーセ
日本訳は この世に帰り来る縁となる煩悩から生じるものをいささかも持たない修行者は
という意味ですね それももう少々意味が違いますけどね
一応パーリ語の言葉から考えてみましょう
ヤッサダラタジャーという何か変な言葉
一応今は意味がわからない
ナサンティケーチっていうのは一般のパーリ語
一つもないんだと このダラタジャーというやつは一つもないんだと
ダラタジャーの意味は後で言います
今はその通りに理解してください
ある人にはまるっきりこのダラタジャーというものはありませんと
このダラタジャーって何でしょうかと次に書いているんですね
オーランアーガマナヤパッチャヤーセ
オーランというのはまた降りてきて
また帰ってきて パッチアセっていうのは観察してやってやってみようではないかと
という意味なんです じゃあまた帰ってきて
じゃあこれやってみようではないかという気持ち
それがダルタジャーの意味が分かりますか
もうちょっと複雑で分からないかもしれませんだけど
まあ例えにしましょう
で 我々はまあ子供を連れてどこかへ行くとする
私たちの何か目的があって
まあ盆踊りに行くと 言って
まあこちらは約束したんだから
なんとかそう約束したとこを全部やって
じゃあ帰ろうと子供を引っ張って
またうちに帰ると で 子供は母親に引っ張られてもう行くんだけど
それ行く途中で何か見たら何か止まりたくなっちゃうんですね
なんかこれ面白いと でもこれで引っ張られていくんだからね
早く行こう 早く行こう
みんな待ってるんだからとかね
で まあ母親が自分の約束したその仕事をして
じゃあ帰ろう帰ろうと帰る
それで子供の頭の中にちょっとしたこと残っちゃうんですね
もう一回戻ってあれ見ようかなと
ちょっと大きい子供だったら
自分が遊んでもいいんですか？と
一人で遊んでもいいんですか？とか言って
その自分 気になったところに気に入ったところに行って
それをみようとする だから我々はもう人生の旅を同じこと
普通の旅にしてください
どこかへみんなで 例えば人
三人で 四人で 五人で グループで旅行したりすると
一人の心にあーあれちょっと面白いなと
買い物をしていると みんなもうまあ一応マニュアルで決まってるんだから
行く店とかね そこでマニュアルで決まってる店にグループで入るんだけど
ちらっと隣の店見たら
あれ何か面白いものあるなとわかるんですよ
わかるんだけど しょうがない
このグループ行動だから
決まってる店に行って
決まってる値段払って
決まってる品物を買ったりはする
でも一人で来られたら
あの店にも行けるのに
あの店にも行けるのにと思っちゃう
隣の道の店にも行けるんだのにと思っちゃうでしょ
そういう思う人もいます
私は知ってる限りでは
日本がどこか分かりませんだけど
やっぱりみんなと一緒だからしょうがないんですよ
でもなんかあれ面白いなと
できればまた一回帰ってきますよっていう気持ちになるんです
あるいは じゃあ今度来たらそれもやりましょうと
ダルタジャーっていうのはその心の働きなんです
京都の 例えば紅葉を見ようとする
行ったのはいいんだけど
大雨で土砂降りでもうどこにも行けないと
言ってもやっぱり紅葉見るんだったらね
もうすごく晴れて まあそこそこ涼しい空気があってとかいう
こう一番気持ちいいものでしょうに
ザーザーと雨が降っている時は全然面白くもなんのない
そこでせっかく行ったんだから
なんとか傘を差しながら
いろいろ苦労しながら
面白いね きれいですね
やっぱりすごいですねと言って早く帰っちゃうでしょうに
やっぱりすごい綺麗ですねとかね
あれちょっと言うだけで心にちょっと残っちゃうでしょうに
やっぱり晴れてあった方がよかったんだよ
じゃあ来年晴れてる日で行くんだと
って決めちゃうんです
それで人生という旅の場合も
毎日毎日我々はまた戻ってきてやるぞという気持ちはいつでも残っちゃうんです
また戻ってきてやるんだという
何やってもその気持ちもありますよ
できればやり直しますと
結婚して式をしたとする
それで万々歳 満足ということではなくて
まあできればやっぱりやり直したいということはあるんです
[笑い]これはごく普通のことなんですよ
例えば何でもいいんですよ
何やったっても じゃあ二度とやるんだったら同じ風にやるんですか？と聞いたら
いえ もし同じことを 2回目でやるようになったら
そうじゃなくて こういう風にこういう風にやるんだと言うでしょ
あれは残りなんです だから料理したところでも
じゃあ今度はこういう風に作りますよ
すぐ行っちゃうんだから
その心の働き だから店に行って買い物して
何か失敗したら 今度行ったらこうしますよとか
あるいはこうした方がよかったのにと思うことは心残りなんですね
そういう心の働きがすべての人類に
生命にあるし それはパーリ語の専門はダルタジャと言うんですね
ダルタというのは疲れたっていうことなんですけどね
この心のこの仕送り これは仕送りそのものというよりは
やっぱりそういうものは出来上がる
この心の働き その自体が問題なんですね
例えば何か心残っちゃってやり直せばいいんでしょ
それで 例えばせっかくご飯食べようと思って外に出て食べたんだけど
なんとか問題があってうまくいかなかったら
じゃあ来週やりましょうと思って
来週やり直す やっちゃえばいいかもしれません
だけど それで問題は解決しないんですね
心にちょっと何か残る機能があるんだから
やっぱり次から次へ次から次へと残っちゃうんですね
何やっても 何をやっても残ることは確かな事実
なぜならば全て不完全だから
完全にできるはずがないんです
そこで 2行目でオーランアガマナーヤ
アーガマナーヤ パッチャーセ
オーランというのはまた戻ってくると
パッチャーセっていうのはよく観察して味わうために
アーガマナーヤっていうのは帰ってくること
オーランというのは下へ
これはどのように理解するかというと
人がこれ輪廻のことなんです
人生の旅なんです 人生の旅をやっている人が死んでしまっちゃえば
そこら辺に行けばいいでしょうね
やっぱりまた輪廻に戻りたくなるんですね
また生を作りたくなるんです
また生まれ変わりたくなるんです
また人生やり直したくなるんです
完璧な満足感では死にません
もう 2度とは人生やりたくないんだ
もう完璧にやりましたと
という気持ちでは死ぬ人はいません
これ以上やることはないんだと思って死ぬ人はいません
ですから 死ぬ時もやっぱりもう一回やり直した方がいいなという気持ちで死ぬんですね
それでまた帰って下へ降りてくると
解脱へ行くんじゃなくて
下へ降りてくるということ
もし我々の心の中で その具体的にいつでも持っているこの
この子の性格 何やってもなんかやり直して
まあやり直したいなとかね
今度やるともっと立派にやるぞという
その働きがこのフィンニの引っ掛けなんですね
それは煩悩の引っ掛けで
それは束縛の引っ掛けで
それは悟れない鍵なんです
それ捨てちゃえば そこのその境地が悟りですよ
すごくまあまあ私から言えばすごい具体的にわかりやすいんです
悟りって何ですか？っていうこと
すごい心理学的で とても心に何かある
このダルタジャというやつは
だから私の後にいろんなお母さんたちがね
小さな子供を連れてあっちこっち行くと
子供たちの足があっちこっちで止まったり引っかかったり
ブレーキかけるでしょうに
子供はブレーキかけるんだけど
足に 母親がでっかくで引っ張っていくんだから
もう母親は知らない 子供はブレーキかけているんだっていうことさえも
そんなことなど引っ張って連れて行っちゃうでしょうに
あの性格は子供の時は明確に見えますよ
ちゃんと子供はブレーキかけますから
足に だから母親は子供を引っ張っていっても
この手に手に手で引っ張るとわかるでしょうね
ある時は子供は飛んでくる
そうすると手は軽い ある時はなんか手が硬く感じるでしょうね
硬く感じる時は子供はもうとっくにブレーキかけてるんですね
なぜブレーキかけたかというと
そこら辺にはなんとなく見たいっていうこと
何かあるんですね だから強引にブレーキかけて持って行っちゃうと
帰ってきて見たいなという気持ちでいっちゃうんですね
これ人生に例えちゃうと
我々はすーっと手を引っ張られてるんです
人生では止まることないんです
子供だったら そんなに見たければどうぞ見てくださいと見させてあげればいいでしょう
でも人生にはストップないでしょ
1 秒1 秒1 秒年取っていくんだから
あ 今日は気持ちいい友達が見つかったんだから
もう時計を止まって遊ぼうっていうことはできません
友達と一緒に遊んでいるんだけど
一緒に年取っていくんですね
だから人生の場合は 母親は子供をどこにも止まらず
止まってもらうことなく引っ張っていくような感じで
で 我々は死まで引っ張られてるんですね
止まることはないんですね
1 秒も だから 見たいものを
聞きたいものを やりたいこといっぱいあるのに
もう死は引っ張られて引っ張られて
じゃあ死んでしまえということを言っちゃうんですね
だからノンストップなんですね
ノンストップ旅をしているんだけど
やっぱりあれもうちょっと見たかったな
これもうちょっとやりたかったなと
その心にこの機能はなくなったら悟りと呼ぶんです
その機能で死んじゃっても悔しくて死んじゃうんですね
なんで私はそんな早く死ななくちゃいけないかと
もうちょっとあれやりたかった
これやりたかったのにと
それで死ぬことがすごく嫌になっちゃうんですね
だから人類は一番使わない言葉
不幸だと思う言葉は死という言葉
みんな死だけ避けるためにいろんなことをやってます
頑張ってます 不死の教授作ったりする
天国を作ったりする 永遠な命のことを作ったりすると
永遠な魂のことを考えたり作ったりする
全部人間作るんです あれなぜ作るかというと
死ぬのは嫌なんですね
なぜ死ぬのは嫌かというと
やっぱりもう一回やり直したいとか
もう一回やってみたいなという気持ちはたくさん心残ってるんですね
それでやっぱりもう一回ダメなんです
できない 死ななくちゃいけないんだから
もう一回若返ってみたいなと思ったって無理でしょうし
ですから 魂やら永遠の命やら天国やら
そういういろんないっぱい話を作ってしまっちゃう
頭の中で 作って自分が誤解して喜んでますけどね
とにかくそういう気持ちを持つ人々は輪廻から脱出しません
生まれては死ぬ 生まれては死ぬ
生まれては死ぬ 生まれては死ぬと
それで誰かがこのやっぱりもうまたもう一回やってみたいなという心にあるこの気持ちだけを消してしまうと
それは悟りなんです 次にヤッサワナタジャナサンティケーチーヴィニバンダーヤバワーヤヘートゥカッパ
次の難しい言葉っていうのはワナタジャという
ワナタンというのはもうすごく膿がいっぱい溜まってるこの怪我のことなんです
傷のことなんですね だからこれは心に傷ができていて
かなり大きい傷なんです
まあ煩悩のことなんですけど
わかりやすく言えば そこでまあ体にいろいろ傷ができたりした
したりすると動けなくなったりすると
それはいいわけに我々は仕事には行かない
家に泊まっている もう動けませんだから
痛いんだから 例えばもう足の骨を折って怪我したりする
それでなんとかつけちゃいますね
つけて それもベッドの上で何か上に何か紐でぶら下がって
足をね そのまんまにしておく
じゃあどこかに行きますかね
その人は 行きたくも行きたくても行けません
それでその人は今日は子供の運動会なのに行ってみたいなと思ったんでも
もうどうしようもないんですね
おとなしく病院にいるんです
骨が折ったんだから そういう例えで考えてください
我々の心にはすごい傷はと傷があって
この傷があるんだから
解脱はしたいんだけど
やっぱしょうがないんだと
変の中に留まっているんです
だから 足の骨を折ったお父さんが子供の運動会には行きたいんだけど
足の骨が折っちゃったんだから病院にいると
それで病院にいることはいいわけにする
運動会に行かないことは
で 心の中に大きな傷があって
その傷っていうのは煩悩
あって我々は引っかかってるんです
それで解脱しようとしない
まあどういうことかというと
家族がいるんだ まだまだ子供は小さいんだからと
やっぱり自分が一人で出ちゃうとね
家内はあまりいい気持ちにならないんだと
なんか変なことやってるんだと批判するんだと
そういう何かいう 瞑想はしたいんだけど
もう旦那が家にない日でないと来られませんと
旦那にバレたら大変だとかね
そういう人は悟れませんよ
いくら来たっても あんな根性がない
頭の智慧がない心では悟るというのは大違い大間違いです
これ大変な世界だからね
誰かに怯えて 誰かにも誰かをわかったとかに
鋭い知恵でやるんだったら別として
別そうで このもう弱気で
もうただ怯えて根性はない
そういう人には悟りにくいんですけどね
とにかく人という何か訳が言う訳がいい加減に言うんじゃなくて
本当に訳があるんです
お父さんの足の骨が折ってるんだったらしょうがないでしょうに
運動会に参加できません
そのように私たちにも
例えば小さな子供がいるんだったら
子供連れて解脱するわけにいきませんでしょうし
ですから そうやって我々はこの
世界にいろんな束縛がある
責任感がいっぱいできてきて
それで痛いんですよ 本当は
だから罠 傷と言うんです
責任が多いんだから 例えば
ある有名な伝統ある家で長男で生まれたりする
全部捨てて 全て捨てて自由になることはできないんですね
だから もう苦労して苦労して
収入にもならないのに
もうもう年 三年  三百年の家の伝統を守らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうと
あれ痛いと思いますけどね
やっぱり引っかかって痛くて苦労して生活しちゃうでしょ
というのもよくありますから
どうやって心にあるこの傷
我々は責任感を感じている
義務感を感じている 義理を感じている
その気持ちが消えちゃったら
そこも悟りの世界ですね
で 最後にあるのは この二悪滅っていうのは
この欲と貪瞋睡眠と怒りと疑い
何でも知らないんだから疑ってしまっちゃうという心のこのもやもやをね
全部なくなる ティンナカタンカト
この推測することは捨ててしまう
カタンカテっていうのは推測なんですね
神がいるだろういないだろうとかね
あの人いい人でしょうか
悪い人でしょうかとかね
それ全て概念ばっかりでね
概念全部取っくに捨てちゃったら
あの人いい人でしょうかな
悪い人でしょうかなとかね
今度の政治はよくやってくれるかな
おそらくやってくれないかな
それいっぱい考える そんなもん何の意味もないんですね
ですから この推測は全部消えちゃうっていうことは
概念捨ててってるならば
その比丘はあの世に行くんだ
あの世もこの世も捨てて
全て捨てて解脱するんだということ
以上です 急に説明しちゃうと私が足りないです
ない この偈っていうのは
この悟ったって一体何ですか？という
すごい具体的な説明なんです